all right on the set now after another
strong debate to Performance Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis how are you
Governor good to see you I'll tell you
what um I've been in California we've
got in Sunday night and we were in
Coronado it happens in the room well
that's what I'm gonna say yeah people
are buzzing about this debate that
you're gonna do so I think it's going to
be incredible we're due but tonight look
there was a lot of bickering on the
stage and you know my thing is is like
look we owe to the American people to
give our vision about how we're going to
reverse this country's Decline and I
think I was able to do that I think some
of the crosstalk if I was at home
watching that I would turn the channel
when I saw that so we were able to I
think rise above that and deliver our
message listen in my view there were a
couple people on that stage in my view
that probably shouldn't have been there
right I mean and I think at that point
it lends itself more to a conversation
um it is interesting
um I think this debate is with you and
the governor is going to be very
interesting so I'm looking forward to
moderating that and I think with 90
minutes that just plenty of breathing
rooms so that will lend itself to more
conversation you know what maybe we can
say since the former president didn't
come here maybe he'd be willing to do
one with you and I I think he owes it to
our voters to come and make the case so
now challenging so this is going to be
Hannity one-on-one debates let's do it
let's do it right I'll do anything
here's the thing though yo it to the
voters to come and make the case no
one's entitled anything you know you can
say oh there's some poll months before
no you got to make the case you got to
go to the voters so I'm going to show up
everywhere I think that that's what we
were able to do and you know there were
some I think some important issues that
were discussed tonight there's also
others that I know you and I have talked
about that weren't discussed but at the
end of the day I think the thing that
was clear for this there's a lot of talk
a lot of people had good things to say
I'm the guy that's done it in Florida I
promised uh we delivered and we're sick
of the talk with Republicans they always
promise all this like what are the two
biggest issues arguing right now the the
debt and the Border you and I have been
talking about this for as long as we've
known each other isn't it time we get a
leader to come in and bring this stuff
into a conclusion and a landing and and
I think if we're able to you know to to
to do that with the nomination and win
the election we're going to be able to
get all this stuff done nobody brought
up the point regarding the border and
and I thought you had a very strong
position of what you would do to close
the border and and you know No Nonsense
get this thing closed it's now become to
me more than anything else the National
Security yes we are catching people that
are on the terror watch list but we're
not vetting anybody we have no idea what
they're back people are coming from
China Russia Iran all of our enemy
countries they're coming across the
border I hope I'm wrong but if I had to
bet my life savings I would bet that
there will be a terrorist attack that
happens in the future of this country
these guys in DC they don't care there's
no urgency I mean some of our guys in
the house care but like the the Elites
in DC they don't care Biden doesn't care
he's missing in action in on this as the
Carnage mounts and I agree I mean I
think that this is above all a national
security issue now there's also nuts and
bolts issues I mean the amount of of
illegals that are pouring in medical
care is being taxed uh schools it's
overwhelming communities far away from
the border you see it in New York City
in New York city so the pain on average
forty thousand dollars per illegal
immigrant okay and they're kicking out
the veterans to make room for real the
veterans never had the four-star hotels
they're building all these facilities
they expect to spend 12 billion dollars
in the next 18 months and you know
they're claiming this came from Governor
Abbott no 87 I think it's been very good
except 13 here's the problem with this
government we have and I think why
people are rightfully so frustrated they
can't tell us how many illegals are
coming across the border they can't tell
us how many uh tanks we left in
Afghanistan they can't tell you where
all the money in Ukraine they can't even
tell you how cocaine got in the White
House and yet they want to go after if
you do 601 transactions fair to the
investigators they spend 10 long days
investigating where that cocaine came
from and came to the conclusion they'll
never get a conclusion
um how is that but in the Menendez case
they actually found the Fingerprints of
the people that handed the envelope so
they claim to Senator Menendez pretty
interesting I can't believe you know he
had all the gold bars there I guess
that's a real Testament to bite
inflation listen I love that people you
need to have that how much is a kilo of
gold worth right you can't make this up
um generally speaking you know I guess
the theme of the night as I watched and
listened to you tonight was okay these
are the tough stances I took in Florida
these are the that's my proven track
record and that's what I want to bring
to the White House I think it's I think
it's leadership and I think it's
deliverables because we can have great
slogeneering we can have great debates
but if we're not ultimately going to get
this done then none of it matters and
one of the things I've been thinking
about lately because preparing here I
looked at Reagan Farewell Address so in
20 2033 in January what would I say to
the American people after serving two
terms and that's really the vision of
you're going to be able to get ahead
again in this country we're an economy
that works for people we're going to
have our sovereignty restored and
borders enforce we're going to make sure
that we have education not
indoctrination we will be the world's
leading superpower we will fend off the
threat from China successfully we're not
going to have crime overrunning every
city in America anymore and we're going
to restore the Constitution so that we
have a limited government that works
beside us and on our behalf not a
weaponized government that comes after
us if we can do that then we will have
restored The Shining City on the hill
that Reagan talks about and we'll be
able to turn over America to our kids
and grandkids better than we found it
Governor thanks for coming by I
appreciate it thank you good to see you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else